hey guys, Pete here. Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 2 was titled a Knight of
the Seven Kingdoms, it was a lot stronger
than the premiere, and it's got me really
excited. this will be my first reaction
recap to go over the major points that
happen in the lead-up to the Battle of
Winterfell if you haven't watched
Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 2 yet then this will obviously contain spoilers .there were some very
emotional character moments in this
episode which is great to see now that
everyone's assembled at Winterfell we
got some payoffs that I've been waiting
for for quite a while. even though I
hadn't guessed that we would see Jamie
Knight Brienne in the episode it was a
fantastic addition. Brienne is one
character who actually embodies what a
knight should be so I was really moved
by this. to have Jamie be the one to do
it was just perfect and I think this is
one of the high points of the episode
the other one that kind of hit me in the
heart was Theon declaring to fight for
Winterfell I expected this to happen of
course but I thought the scene was done
really well. the one thing I wasn't in
love with while watching was Jon
revealing his parentage to Daenerys this
was mainly because of the timing since
you could tell it wasn't gonna get
resolved as it was going down I checked
how much time was left in the episode
and knew right away they would get
interrupted by the White Walkers arrival
having had some time to think about it
now I guess it makes sense to set up the
second half of the season but at the
time knowing that the conversation would
get cut short spoiled it for me a bit. my
initial response overall though was that
this is a strong episode now let's go
back and look at everything that
happened from the beginning. we started
out with Jamie being pulled up by
Daenerys about killing her father and we
see that Sansa is on her side I
mentioned in my trailer breakdown that
we knew what the outcome of this would
be but I liked what Jamie said when he
was confronted with his past he said, "you
want me to apologise? I won't. we were at
war, everything I did I did for my house
and my family. I'd do it all again."
I enjoyed that and how it highlights the
motivation of the characters and brings
real gravity to what they're facing now
of course Bran delivers the words, "the
things we do for love" which is what
Jamie said just before he pushed him out
of the window in season 1. I thought it
was kind of funny that Jamie
acknowledged that, Sansa gave him a look,
and then things just moved along like
nothing happened sort of like oh that's
just Bran sometimes he says things. I was
hoping for a Kingslayer reveal here that
might have even restored some of his
honor but instead we see Brienne vouch
for him which was expected and that was
enough to sway Sansa. Jon predictably
just wants more fighters so the
situation ends up resolved. before they
leave the hall we see that Jon slips out
without saying anything to Daenerys and
Jamie looks at Bran to acknowledge that
he knows. I thought it was a nice touch
in the scene that Jamie echoes what
Brienne told him in the dragon pit in
season 7 and that's right before she
speaks up for him in the transition. we
see that Daenerys is pissed with Tyrion
and she has good reason to be
Tyrion acknowledges the situation by
telling Varys and Jorah that one of them
will probably be wearing the hand of the
queen pin before it's all over. we head
to the forge where the production of
dragonglass weapons is in overdriv.e Arya
arrives to ask Gendry about her weapon
and in my notes for this scene I wrote
"thick looks between these two" as in
she's there to find out about the weapon,
she asked him about the army the dead
since he's seen them, but there is
something else going on you can feel it
I think it worked out well and I like
seeing the side of Arya
next we go to the Winterfell weirwood where
Jamie approaches Bran to apologize. last
night when I was trying to sleep I was
thinking about this scene and how I was
hoping we were gonna get a vision to
pick a part in between these two
episodes. that doesn't happen but I'll
talk about that more in the battle
preparation scene. what we do get is that
Bran isn't angry at Jamie or angry at
anyone for that matter. he echoes what
Jaime said about protecting his family
tells him that he wouldn't be able to
help in this fight if he let them murder
him and when Jamie says what about
afterwards Bran delivers the ominous how
do you know there is an afterwards? even
though I think everyone expected this to
be the outcome of their reunion I
thought the acting was really good here
by both characters and I'm really liking
season 8 bran compared to what we saw
last season. what this scene isn't though
is conclusive as to what Bran knows
about does he believe Jamie has a unique
role to play in the battle or does he
fear that there
and afterward it's not really clear for
now we just have to chalk it up to being
some three-eyed Raven type stuff and
move on we get the next proper reunion
between Jaime and Tyrion after we get a
glimpse of all the preparation going on
in the art at Winterfell
they talk about the Daenerys and Cersei my
big takeaway here is that Tyrion
believed Cersei and that being pregnant
had changed her this was a big topic of
conversation and speculation in the
offseason because of how they cut that
scene where we last saw them together
that perhaps Tyrion had cut some kind of
deal with Cersei but here talking to his
brother who we wouldn't expect him to
lie to it doesn't appear to be the case
we can't know for sure what they said
after the camera cut away but at least
for now it appears Tyrion believed that
she would send her army north after he
left that room the brothers seemed happy
to be back together and they talked
about dying in Winterfell what got me
really excited about this scene was the
look of the Winterfell set itself as we
saw the preparation going on around them
you can see how the show has expanded
things and how big of an impact that
might make on next week's episode we get a lot of looks at the reinforcements and
the way the side of the living are
hoping to stop the approaching army we
get some training with Pod and then we
see Jaime go to Brienne he tells her
that he wants to fight for her and it
looks sort of like she's not really sure
how to deal with the new Jaime so they
leave it at that
the next scene was a bit of a surprise
when we saw this image of Daenerys in
her room a few times in the trailers
there was a lot of speculation about
what was happening here it turns out
Jorah is there to advise her to ease up
on Tyrion and he also suggests that she
should go talk with Sansa to put
things right
it didn't dawn on me at the time but
knowing where we last see Jorah in this
episode I realized that this may be the
last time we see Jorah and Daenerys
sharing a scene like this I think it's
fitting that he gives her good advice
and I'm glad they moved this whole idea
of her squabbling with Sonsa along she
goes to sunset and things start off
pretty well we see her be diplomatic and
make some progress in building a good
working relationship talk turns to Jon
we see Sansa is protective of her
brother
worried that he might be manipulated
because he's in love and Daenerys does a
good job of pointing out that she
followed Jon North and not the other
way around they even have a laugh about
Jon's height before things take a turn
Sansa echoes Jamie's question to Bran
when she asks what happens afterwards
things get noticeably tense when she
starts asking about the status of the
north after the war is over
but of course we get maester Wolkan come in and interrupts I'll talk about this
at the end of the video since we have
two big interruptions before the episode
is done we get Theon's arrival and
I'll tell it true I almost teared up
when he said he wants to fight for
Winterfell even writing about it now
it's just one of those scenes I didn't
necessarily expect to feel something
about but man it worked it was really
good Theon has officially come full
circle from one of the least likeable
characters on the show to make it
through a horrible couple of seasons of
hardships and make it out on the other
side after that we get a look at all the
northerners who have arrived at
Winterfell Davos is dishing out food
preparing the cannon fodder by giving
them encouraging words and we get a nice
exchange that involves The Onion Knight
a small girl and Gilly I for one am glad
they included this scene to emphasize
what this fight is all about of course
the girl has a scar so it reminds us of
Shireen but we get to see Davos do what
he does best and we also get to see a
nice exchange with Gilly who will be in
the crypts when all hell breaks loose
horns blow announcing the arrival of
tormund barrack and Edie they delivered
the news at the umbers and everyone else
from the north of Winterfell who weren't
there yet are now fighting alongside the
dead they also explain that the White
Walkers will arrive before morning we
get a voiceover from John while we see
everyone getting ready and then we cut
to this war planning session or war
Council whatever you want to call it I
didn't pay it much mind on first watch
but check out the setup on the map in
front of them it really shows what
they're expecting how they're expecting
to be outnumbered it comes out that they
need to defeat the night king - when
Jamie says if that's true he'll never
expose himself and then bran cuts in I
enjoyed this on so many levels
bran explains that the night king will
expose himself because he will come for
him that he's tried it many times before
with many different three-eyed Ravens
then Sam becomes all of us and says why
what does he want
he gets the ask the question we all want
to know the answer to and Bran answers
that he wants an endless night he wants
to erase this world and I'm its memory
Sam fills in the blanks of why this
makes sense and then the looks on
everyone's face when Bran reveals the
night Kings mark is just fantastic
I wonder what's going through their
heads as he's telling them that he is
the target and that he has this mark on
him so the night king always knows where
he is we don't get to find that out but
we do find out that brand wants to wait
out in the open at the gods blood to
draw the night king to him I have always
thought that that would be the deal that
he was coming for bran and I mentioned
the trap would probably be necessary and
my trailer breakdown for this episode we
get an idea how they are planning on
doing that John says they need to keep
the Dragons closed to protect bran but
not too close to keep the night king
away when Arya asked if dragons fire
will stop him
bran and miss he doesn't know because
it's never been done before he owned
steps up to protect him with the
Ironborn and we also learned that they
are planning on starting a fire around
the castle and the trenches we've seen
them dig Daenerys tells Tyrion that she
wants him to stay in the crypts because
he's too important to her and with their
plan in place we move on John beats it
out of the room again when it looks
clear that Dany wants to talk to him
Tyrion pulls up a chair to hear brans
story after the others have left and I
think that's a pretty nice way to ending
there could be something going on there
but I'm not gonna speculate that right
now back outside we get a one on one
scene with Messandei and Greyworm talk
about how they don't really fit in
Westeros and make plans to go to not
after the war is over it's a good scene
but I have to point this out I mentioned
that the Jorah and Daenerys one-on-one
scene might be the last we see them
share and I feel like this is the same
thing I have predicted that both Jorah
and greyworm will die in the
battle and this scene makes it feel all
too real we go to the top of the walls
and who is that in the corner of the
screen Ghost finally shows up and no one
as much as mentions in apparently John
and his Direwolf had their reunion
off-screen somewhere else at a different
time but either way it's nice to see him
even if it's completely underwhelming
Sam asked John if he's told Dany yet
and we see that it's eating him up Edd
joins them and we get our Nights Watch
reunion which he punctuates for us by
saying and now our watch begins it's
great to see these three together and we
get a little comedy to lighten things up
pre-battle
personally I cracked up when Sam added
that he stole a considerable number of
books from the Citadel library to his
list of badassery it's another scene
that I'm so glad they gave us but it
ends on a somber note when Edd says "last man left burn the rest of us" Jamie and
Tyrion had an exchange where they think
about how Tywin would feel that both of
his sons were likely going to die
fighting for the Starks it's a nice
moment that reminds us how far both of
these characters have come and then we
get more characters come in Brienne and
pod arrive Davos and torment follow next
and we get a story from torment about
where he gets the name Giantsbane
he explains that he killed a giant when
he was 10 climbed into bed with his wife
who suckled him for three months
thinking it was her baby after that we
get a better reunion with the hound and
Arya she asked why he's there when was
the last time he fought for someone else
and he points out that he fought for her
it's going well but Beric arrival
prompts Arya to leave as she doesn't
want to spend her final hours with two
miserable old shits Arya then gets her
weapon and seems pretty happy with it we
don't really get a super close look at
it she asked Gendry why Melisandre
wanted him finds out that he is Robert
Baratheon bastard as she's talking about
Melisandre we see things take a turn and
she actually makes a move on him it's
pulled off pretty well and it works to
underline the severity of the situation
once again I was never big on the idea
these two coming together romantically
their relationship seemed sort of like a
sibling one because they were young but
sometime really soon they're going to be
fighting for their life it totally works
that Arya would want to
have this experience before that happens
and I'm glad they added it also ties in
with what I was saying in last week's
recap it's nice to see some humanity and
her character again and here she shows
us another brand new side that we
haven't seen before in the after the
episode the showrunner said they wanted
to show how this was probably everyone's
last night or at least the characters
were preparing for the inevitability
that some of them weren't going to make
it through this they wanted to show how
different characters would handle it and
I think it works really well that they
put this scene with Arya in there. back
where the other characters have gathered
to stay warm tyrion points out the fact
that almost everyone in the room had
fought Starks at one time or another and
that now they're all gathered in their
castle ready to defend it together in
the process of recalling the battles
they survived it comes out that Brienne
isn't a night which torment can't
believe I have to say that I wasn't a
fan of torment following Brienne around
and laying it on heavy this entire
episode but if the payoff was for
Brianza to get knighted then I'm
completely fine with it
I mentioned this moment earlier because
to me this is just so huge there's an
idea of what a knight is or should be
that permeates the writing of this
series a series that consists of
characters created by an author who
likes to write them in shades of gray
because of that Brienne has always stood
out as being like what a true knight
should be but would never be able to
carry that title because she's a woman
watching her kneel and arise as the
knight of the Seven Kingdoms still gives
me goosebumps just thinking about it in
the name of the warrior I charge you to
be brave in the name of the Father
I charge you to be just in the name of
the mother I charge you to defend the
innocent and damn just damn him
after that we hear Lyanna Mormont tell
her cousin Jorah that she will not hide
underground in the crypts during the
battle no way Jorah is gonna talk her
into it and we see Sam give him Hart's
Bane Sam explains that Giora Mormont
taught him to do what's right and it's
right for Jorah to wield the house Tarly
Valyrian steel blade in the upcoming
battle then speaking of goosebumps
Tyrion asked for a song and pod steps up
to start singing this was a fantastic
to book readers as you realize it's
Jenny song just as the camera starts to
travel from character to character
it's magical if not completely
depressing because we know they won't
all live through the coming episode
Jenny song is one book readers would
know and it would take like entire video
to explain it so I won't but it's also
interesting because when HBO put up the
recording of it they actually called it
Jenny of old stones
anyways too much to get into here but
damn that's good and I imagine Bryan
cogman who is credited as the writer of
this episode is responsible for that so
Bravo before we go into the crypts we
see Sam and Gilly laying in bed with
little Sam we see Sansa and Theon giving
each other some looks Aria is laying
awake in bed work injury sleeping grey
worm kissing Masson day and Jorah going
out into the field all with pod
delivering the refrain of and she never
wanted to leave never wanted to leave
killed it in the crypts John is in front
of his mother statue when Daenerys comes
to him he explains that Rhaegar and
Lyanna are in love and were married and
then drops the truth bomb we have been
waiting to see
I think Kit Harington and Emilia Clarke
both did a good job of delivering the
scene but as I mentioned at the
beginning knowing they were going to cut
this thing off kind of took away from it
it's really completely unresolved when
they hear the horns blow outside when
they do go up we see the camera pull
away from Tyrion on the battlements and
get our first glimpse of the White
Walkers we'd seen the whole of the horse
we knew they were coming we figured
that's where the episodes gonna end but
we do actually see the White Walkers
themselves it's clear that the knight
King isn't pictured with them but there
are at least eight White Walkers not
White's on horseback that we see close
up when you brighten up the picture and
look closely it appears that there is a
line of horses that goes out all the way
across the battlefield I can't say for
sure but it looks like there may be a
lot more White Walkers than were
originally believed but it's also
possible they have White's on horseback
too so I'm just gonna leave it there for
now I want to get this video finished
and then I'll go back and take a closer
look already
thirty five hundred words here so my
idea of doing a quick recap is already
getting away from me but at the very
least it's interesting to see that they
have so many people on horseback the
episode ends there and the table is
officially set for the battle we've all
been waiting to see there are a lot of
great moments we learned some important
information and I almost teared up more
than once I mentioned that I didn't like
the interrupted conversation with
Daenerys and I definitely don't both
interrupted conversations with the nurse
I should say I can see and accept that
they might have thought this was the
best way to set up the back half of the
season
hmm we have to keep in mind that these
are the short episodes and there is
still a lot of story after the battle
but I'm not sure how I'm feeling about
that I was also somewhat disappointed
that we didn't get a weirwood vision
from brand but felt a little bit better
about that when we found out that he was
going to be hanging out by the tree
during the battle this could make for
some interesting viewing it also opens
the door for him to confront the knight
King in the weirwood net I really like
that they fit in some character moments
here so many of them really when you
think back I think most of us thought
that the conflict with Dany and John
coming to terms with his parentage might
push these other characters out of the
picture so it's nice that we got to see
some of these conversations the other
side of that though is that they'll
probably be those characters last
moments but hey we know it's coming to
an end so let's take what we can get I
thought the idea of giving us an answer
as to what the knight King wants is okay
the way that they delivered it if you
describe this to me I would think it
sounded horrible but watching it it felt
pretty natural based on what's going on
and how they have to move forward I
think it's clear that bran doesn't know
exactly what they need to do or how
they're going to turn out in the actual
battle I think Theon is a great
candidate to have with him but I've been
thinking that the night King would go
after Bran that they would need a plan
and they could use him in a trap type
situation so I'm pretty alright with it
as far as what we saw here in this
episode in closing I think it was a good
episode and it's
couraging for the rest of season 8 the
build-up here didn't seem nearly as
rushed as some of the things in the
first episode since it ended like I
thought it would the only character who
I think will definitely show up after
the battle starts as Melisandre I can't
say for sure but I feel like John and
Daenerys won't talk about their
situation again not until the battles
over anyways that actually could be
encouraging if you don't want them to
die in the battle I mean in my mind if
you're gonna leave that hanging then
it's a sign that there's probably gonna
be a reckoning that'll happen with it
later let me know what you guys think
though what did you think of the episode
what were your favorite moments what do
you think is going to happen I'll make
my episode 3 trailer breakdown after
this because I have to travel this week
and my schedule is gonna be a little bit
different please like the video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you want to follow along with
the rest of the season with me I want to
take a second to tell my viewers that I
really appreciate your support over the
years that's it for now guys I will talk
to you soon